[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
Josh, welcome to Coffee
With A Googler.
JOSH DILLON: Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
you work on something
called the Distributions
API, and that
brings about
probabilistic programming.
What's that all about?
JOSH DILLON: Yeah,
so this is something
that myself and my team
were really excited about.
So I think a little
history is in order.
So TensorFlow did a
number of amazing things.
Maybe one of the
most amazing is how
they made training deep neural
nets easy-- or relatively easy.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's a lot
easier than it used to be.
JOSH DILLON: It's a lot
And this has resulted
in a flurry of research
and exciting results
and solving problems
that otherwise seemed
impossible, or at least,
very difficult to solve.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
JOSH DILLON: So
before neural nets
were all the hotness, many
machine learning folks,
including myself,
sort of consider
ourselves probabilistic
machine learning as, like,
a specialization.
And we want to be a
part of the new hotness.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Who doesn't?
JOSH DILLON: Who doesn't?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I got the logo.
JOSH DILLON: So that's where
Distributions enters the story.
We think that
TensorFlow doesn't have
to be just a language
for fitting neural nets.
It can be a language
for statisticians.
It can be a language for doing
probability first machine
learning, for fusing neural
nets with sort of older ideas
and getting something
that's greater
than the sum of its parts.
So Distributions is
a tiny Lego piece
that tries to make that
just a little bit easier.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
I noticed you recently
published a paper on
the Distributions API
explaining what it's all about.
Could you give us
the brief summary?
JOSH DILLON: Yeah.
So we wrote just
a white paper sort
of showing all of
the cool things that
can be done when you mix
TensorFlow intrinsics
and this Distributions API.
It's actually pretty simple.
But I think the real power comes
from the breadth of the API,
in terms of the number
of Distributions
that are included, as well
as the way they sort of plug
and play with
TensorFlow workflows.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
JOSH DILLON: Let's call it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
I'll be honest with you.
When I first started
seeing something called
a Distributions API, I was
like, hey cool, something
I can use to
distribute my models.
But--
JOSH DILLON: Yeah, maybe
we should have renamed it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Shall
we start refactoring?
JOSH DILLON: If you want
to refactor, by all means.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
going to be a bit of work.
But it's not about
distributing apps, right?
JOSH DILLON: It's not about
distributing apps, no.
It's about encoding
properties of random variables
in an easy to use framework.
So a random variable is a
way to represent uncertainty,
let's say.
And there are several useful
properties that it has.
You may ask, what's the average
under this random variable?
You may ask, what's the variance
So distribution just
collects these properties.
That's not super exciting.
I think what's
slightly more exciting
is the way we organize the
library automatically takes
advantage of modern hardware.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JOSH DILLON: So
we have something
we call "batch semantics,"
which is a TensorFlow idea.
And it means that
you can parameterize
one distribution in
many different ways
and take advantage
of SIMD instructions.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So I noticed in your paper,
you spoke a little bit
about Distributions.
But you also mentioned these
things called "bijectors."
JOSH DILLON: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's a fabulous name,
but what exactly is a bijector?
JOSH DILLON: So we actually
named it a bijector so,
that way, if you
Google searched for it,
you would only find that word.
A bijector is a
very simple idea.
It is a function of a tensor.
And where this fits
into the Distribution
API is, presumably,
that tensor is itself
a sample from some distribution.
So a bijector is a way of
transforming one distribution
into another distribution.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JOSH DILLON: That's
useful, because if we
didn't have that concept, we
have like 60 distributions now.
We may have 600
distributions if we
tried to implement
all transformations
of all distributions.
There's something called
a lognormal, which
is E to the normal
distribution, let's say.
And we don't actually implement
that as a first class citizen.
To achieve that, you
would transform a Gaussian
distribution with the
exponential bijector.
And now you have lognormal.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
So it's a way that you can
combine and chop and change
distributions.
JOSH DILLON: Exactly.
Yeah.
Exactly.
The idea is, distributions
are sources of stochasticity
or randomness, and bijectors are
deterministic transformations
of those sources of randomness.
So there is a kind
of dichotomy there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Interesting.
So just taking a step back
for a second and just think,
why is probabilistic
programming, in your view--
why is it necessary,
and what does it
bring to the table
for developers?
JOSH DILLON: Yeah that's
an exciting question.
So I like to think of
probabilistic programming
as being a formalism for
reasoning under uncertainty.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JOSH DILLON: I like
that definition,
because I can't think of
something that doesn't
fit into that definition.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Those
are the best definitions.
JOSH DILLON: Those are
the best definitions.
Science is you
make a hypothesis,
you verify that hypothesis
with some empirical study.
But we might imagine
that the third time
you ran your experiment, you
got a totally different result.
It doesn't mean your
hypothesis is wrong.
It just means that, guess
what, nature has randomness.
So having a way to make it
easy to specify uncertainty
and to perform inference
and reasoning on it
means that you can sort of tease
out the signal from the noise.
And doing so in a formal
way keeps you honest.
It means that you can't claim
"I have a cure for cancer,"
when in fact, it works
only one out of a million.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
Got it.
And also for safety
reasons, right, if you're
doing something like--
JOSH DILLON: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
This is a green light.
JOSH DILLON: Absolutely.
Suppose you have
a machine learning
algorithm trying to detect
if it's a green light.
If you were only 2% sure
that it's a green light,
you probably should stop.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Exactly, or don't go.
JOSH DILLON: Don't go, yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
But then if it's
97% or if it's 98%--
JOSH DILLON: So
that's the question.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
--that's when you start.
JOSH DILLON: The nice
thing about having
some notion of uncertainty
in your predictive system
is you can weigh the opportunity
cost of action or inaction.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it
might seem like a lot of this
is very theoretical
and very mathematical,
but it's also very
concrete, right.
As soon as you build your
first neural network,
as soon as you build
a neuron, that's
entirely based on probability.
JOSH DILLON: Yeah,
it's interesting you
say it's theoretical, because
machine learning likes to boil
things down to accuracy.
I have some algorithm, and
it achieves 97% accuracy
on detecting handwritten digits.
That's not how the real
world actually works.
The whole point of having
a machine-learned model
is you're going to
make some choice.
And so I think it's immensely
practical to have a system that
tells you, look, this is the
choice I think you should make,
but this is how much
you should trust me.
That seems like actually
not theoretical.
That seems like what we all
really want or maybe even need.
And so if you take a
probabilistic first viewpoint,
you can start to design systems
that have this capability.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Right, and to be
able to get that
probability, you
need like things
like loss functions,
and you plug a
distribution into that.
So by having tons
of distributions,
it gives you the ability
to chop and change
to see what works best for you.
JOSH DILLON: And not just tons
of distributions, but ways
to change them while preserving
the computational properties.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
that's the bijectors.
JOSH DILLON: And that's
the bijector, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So say I'm getting started
in machine learning,
and even getting started
in machine learning
is a hard enough thing.
But what advice
would you give me
to be able to optimize
what I'm doing?
Any good pointers that you
would have from your background?
JOSH DILLON: So I do not have
neural network as a background.
But I like to think
of neural nets--
although this may be
heretical-- as very fancy forms
of regression.
Regression is a relatively old--
actually, an old
idea in statistics,
and relatively old
in machine learning,
in which you try to predict a
response, given some evidence.
That's what a neural
net does, too.
So I think to get started,
we have this thing called
trainable distributions, which
basically take a tensor that
is your evidence, and it
gives you back a distribution
from which you could plug in,
say, minus distribution dot log
prob of your labels as a
loss into an optimizer.
So the examples we have there
show just how easy it is
to do regression in TensorFlow.
And the nice part about
that is, as you add more
sophistication-- different
layers, in TensorFlow parlance,
with different activations,
nonlinear functions
of the output of those layers--
now you can get state of
the art machine learning
sophistication.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool, cool.
And obviously, if I'm
going beyond beginning,
and I want to start getting
into Distributions what--
I mean, I guess read your
paper would be good advice.
JOSH DILLON: Yeah,
so, the white paper
has a lot of examples that show
just the power of this really
simple idea.
And those are my
favorite kinds of ideas,
because I actually get them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
always the best kind, right?
JOSH DILLON: That's
the best kind of idea.
LAURENCE MORONEY: No
point having an idea
that nobody understands.
JOSH DILLON: Especially me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well,
thank you so much, Josh.
This has been so much fun, and
it's really, really digging
down into stuff that I formerly
really didn't understand.
But having read your
paper and having
played with some
of this stuff, I
can really begin to see
where this is going.
JOSH DILLON: I'm
happy to hear that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
thanks very much, Josh.
That was fascinating.
And thank you, too, for
watching this episode of Coffee
With A Googler.
If you have any
questions for me,
or if you have any
questions for Josh,
please leave them in
the comments below.
And don't forget to hit
that subscribe button.
Oh, and by the way, be
sure to check out our brand
new TensorFlow
channel on YouTube.
Thank you.